-Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show
you five different tweets,
and we're all going to vote on
whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You see them there?
You can vote for
all of them, by the way.
every single one of them.
-Really?
-Yeah, it's never been done.
-But you can.
-But -- Well, the whole audience
has never voted for all of them,
but we can do it tonight
if we feel like doing it.
Or you can vote for
none of them.
I just want you
to have a good time.
You're here.
You're at the
"The Tonight Show."
I want you to
have fun, enjoy, and relax.
Higgins, Roots,
you guys have clickers, too?
-Got it.
-Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a shared experience.
Alright,
are you guys ready for this?
The first tweet is...
Hey, there you go.
♪♪
Wow.
-Wow! Thank you, no.
-I didn't even vote yet, but
I don't even know if I have to.
-Might be the first zero.
-"Screw it, I'm going to get
my 2023 glasses prescription."
-Because you wouldn't do that.
-You wear 'em all --
You wear 'em forever.
-You wouldn't normally do that.
-Reading glasses,
whatever you like.
-Yeah, yeah. That's the joke.
-I can already tell, just by --
this is a very honest audience.
-I'm going to say --
I'm gonna say less than 70.
-I saw some people put
the clickers down at one point.
-I saw some people leave.
-They refuse to vote.
Do we have to even
check the results?
Alright, let's see the results.
The votes are in.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
34.
-Oh, my God. 147.
-Wow!
-Might be the worst one yet.
-Gosh! I'm writing that down.
-Here's the other thing --
they all don't
necessarily get better.
-Right.
-Okay, here we go.
This next one says...
♪♪
Wow.
You sit in -- You can move.
You can move.
You don't have to -- Everyone's
just kind of sitting there.
So, if you don't hear the
tree fall, did it happen?
-Yeah. How egotistical.
-Oh, move on. Yeah.
-Are you talking to the tree or
the person who didn't hear it?
-The person that didn't hear.
-Don't go out on a limb
on this one.
I just want to know --
are you talking about the tree?
[ Rimshot ]
Are you gonna leave?
-I'm stumped.
-Oh, yeah.
♪♪
Either way, those are all
getting bigger laughs
than what -- Let's see
the results on this one here.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
-Alright. Again, you don't have
to be that honest, okay?
This is more for
entertainment's sake.
-For fun. We're goofing off.
Happy New Year!
-"If it didn't fall,
I don't know, did it happen?"
-"Hey, man."
-"Yeah, we did have a party,
Larry, and you weren't there."
Alright, here we go.
This next one says...
"Really? You are?"
-"Really?"
-"Wow!"
-"You dress like that?
Wow!"
-"I can take my shoes off
in your place?"
-"This is what you care about?"
-Let's see the results
on this one.
It feels better.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
-There we go.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now we're talking.
-Wow!
-Now we're cooking with gas.
Now we're talking.
-That's more than
the combined --
-I'm loving this right here.
Yeah, that one...
Check out this one here.
-Come on!
-I feel that one.
People are nodding their heads.
People are smiling.
Look at the difference.
-Yeah, come on.
-People are smiling
and having a good time.
That's what I'm talking about.
Alright, here we go.
What do you think?
-It's got to be big.
-You feeling good?
-Yes.
-Let's see the results.
Can you beat -- Let's see
the results on this one.
-Whoa!
-Oh, yeah, baby!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! Come on!
-177.
-That was --
That's hard to beat.
That was great.
Alright, that's good.
So even if nothing happens,
that happened.
Yeah, okay, good.
I appreciate --
-Is this the last one?
-This is the last one here.
-Ooh!
-It says...
♪♪
I think --
Password's gonna win, I think.
-Yeah.
-I feel like
password's gonna win.
-Password. Password.
-People are yelling
"password" out.
-Not the game?
-They're feeling it.
No, no. They like that tweet.
It's password.
Alright. Ready?
What do you think?
Password?
-Well, it's gotta beat 177.
-Password or pickle jar, right?
-This is 130-something.
-You think 130-something?
-Yeah, I think
it's around there, 140.
Yep, I'm with Quest.
But 177 is gonna take it.
-I'm gonna bid --
I'm gonna bid 150.
-I'll take 177.
-Let's see the results.
Oh! Hey, not bad!
-Oh!
-You're right, everybody!
The winner was number four.
[ Dinging ]
That is the new password!
That's what I'm talking about!
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet" right now,
and enjoy.